[Musique]
fac ça c'est tout mais gratuite et
geneviève primo s'adonnent au couplage
depuis une dizaine d'années pour 2021 ça
va l'être dimanche 817 $ qu'on a acheté
1029 de laquelle j'ai payé dans nos
poches et les points accumulés
1863 et 50 ans points pc avec le temps
et la développer plusieurs astuces
j'envoie des lettres de compliments aux
compagnies je demande des couples c'est
toujours des gratuités pour faire
connaître leurs produits
des fois il y en a 1 2 3 4 dans l'
enveloppe elle accumule aussi évidemment
des coupons rabais plus standard sur des
sites internet sur des fois dans le
publi-sac sur les produits beaucoup
puis dans les épiceries évidemment il ya
beaucoup de concours d'affichés elle
utilise ces coupons seulement lorsque le
produit est offert un rabais aux
magasins et elle maximise les points des
programmes de fidélité moi je vais
jamais à la pharmacie si c'est pas un
vain fois les points dans ces 30% de
remise sur ma carte à points elle
constate par contre que les promotions
sont moins nombreux ces temps ci c'est
plus difficile je trouve cette année
parce que justement des produits sont
tellement plus cher que tu es des fois
il ya un peu moins de coupons ce n'est
pas qu'une impression selon sylvain
charlebois vraiment de façon générale
les radars magasins les circulaires tout
ça s'il y en a de moins en moins depuis
les vues de la part des livres c'est la
survie c'est travailler avec la chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui est à défiant
déjà les coupons sont en général moins
généreux au canada il n'est pas possible
de les cumuler contrairement aux états
unis mais avec l'inflation les
détaillants devront probablement être
peu plus généreux je sais pas si on va
voir plus de coupes adage moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on va faire un effort ce
portable que soit deux par programme de
loyauté plus généreux ou plus de crau ou
autre chose et les consommateurs ne
devraient pas être génie d'utiliser des
coupons en magasin qu'ils soient papier
ou électronique et sont toujours les
bienvenus josé pour nous c'est un moyen
de faire connaître des différents
produits on sait que avec les coûts de
l'inflation est un ménage aurait des
difficultés à produire acheter certains
produits alimentaires j'ai des boucs
prendre 4 $ pour cela le cachemire va
être complètement gratuit geneviève
martin utilise environ 20% de ce qu'ils
achètent il donne le reste à des proches
et à des organismes communautaires c'est
ce qu'on aurait cumulé logera au cours
des deux derniers mois
deux derniers mois et demi donc on est
pas mal prêt pour faire un don d'un
repas très long cinq ans de bénévolat
dans le fond parce que je n'aurais
peut-être pas nécessairement le temps
d'aller faire du bénévole du bénévolat
quelque part en dehors de mes heures de
travail mais là ça ça se fait de la
maison sec
oui on redonne au suivant le couple
consacre environ une quinzaine d'heures
par semaine au couplage
c'est marie claude morin radio canada à
laval
[Musique]